Robert Downey jr. is in it Jeff Bridges
bald head the cartoony moment someone
breathes fire is not preceded by them
drinking their first glass of whiskey I
mean this is a kid's film isn't it but
standard protocol pepper ass fact that
an Audi commercial was created using
clips from this movie bonus round
I and all the words with the letter I
said in the movie make some Three
Stooges jokes about the bad slapstick in
the movie so here here is my sense
suggestion it just immediately popped
into my head in the scene where Tony
jumps onto the Iron Man suit in the air
in order to suit up you could say this
scene does not contain a lapdance it's
funny because this is the moment where a
lap dance is most unlikely to happen
also it's nice to keep the tradition
ongoing of saying this phrase as you
have previously said it many times in
the past 5 why is there a bunny the fact
that pepper didn't die I love pepper but
Tony has other lady interests and
killing her off would have been a good
move for the movie you should make jokes
about pepper the condiment your lazy
sins are your job Robert Downey jr.
after the movie was made he no longer
wanted to be Iron Man in any other
movies my friend spoiled this movie for
me sad face when the produce fire formed
their bodies um equals mc2 the movie
expected you to see the Avengers in the
fear in men lazer this movie exists
first movie has a highly choppy flow of
events why is the movie take place in
Kentucky
the fucking villain is named after a
fruit I am man is not made out of iron
bonus round for character douchebaggery
x' can you please do a video on
everything wrong with Man of Steel the
last Superman movie oh and the plot to
this movie is pretty much the same as
the indivisible at the end of the movie
when Zod and Superman crash into the
Hubble I was thinking something like
from all the random space debris you had
to just pick the Hubble didn't you Nolan
threesome with the robot is not allowed
Disney owns Marvel literally Marvel and
all their characters are Mickey speech
so have fun
what if a shark eats it
I can be a dentist please confirm the
receipt of sins I sent you it has been
three weeks the black eye doesn't die
sorry for racism I know the video
already up but can you please please try
to add this sin terrible movie does huge
box-office date